[Music]
countess LuAnn de Lesseps steps out with
a new man and he's is some intense drama
on the Real Housewives of New York City
there's always drama the countess was
joined by a dapper gentleman Tuesday
night in New York City to celebrate the
beauty issue of Bella New York magazine
always his friends just a friend for now
LuAnn was in good spirits on the red
carpet a far cry from what's to come on
Real Housewives of New York City they
charged me with resisting arrest
oh my god weights you see the trip in
the futur sure is I mean the end of the
trip and you know and then it's the
holidays so we all kind of know what
happens during the holidays to me
they're all very supportive of me
they've been great you know but there's
definitely shifts and you're gonna see
Bethenny I got to get closer and and
some of us get not as close I'm really
happy right now I'm doing what I love
and I'm free I been through a lot this
last year so I'm just really thriving
yes she is these days LuAnn is staying
busy with her hashtag countess and
Friends cabaret show I love to sing I
love to tell jokes and I love to host
people so cabaret is really a great
venue for me and of course working on
her fitness I'm a runner I'm a you know
I'm always busy and you know I think you
just got to keep it moving and and eat
well and you know be happy I really
think that's achiever
[Music]
[Applause]